[Music]
Adam lefko NBA on TNT also Bleacher
Report host and Eagles fan Adam is
hosting NBA on TNT tonight Sons Net 7 30
Eastern followed by Thunder Lakers 10
Eastern the doubleheader is on TNT
always good to see uh Adam joining us on
the program as an NBA fan what is LeBron
breaking the all-time scoring record
mean to you
it means that I'm going to have Shaq
lean over and go hey now that he's past
Kareem is he number one all time I think
it's another feather in the cap another
accomplishment of the is LeBron the
greatest player of all time discussion I
think for me
I I I went back and I was reading Howard
Beck's article about the night in which
Kareem broke it and chick Hearn said no
one will ever beat this you have to be
healthy for 15 years in a row you can't
miss a game it's never gonna happen and
that's how I feel about LeBron's record
right now Kareem went on to score I
think like 7 000 more points once he
broke wilt's record so you know LeBron's
gonna add just as much
um it feels like an unbeatable record
but I could imagine somebody's like one
of these young kids sleeping in like a
hyperbaric chamber for his entire career
never eating a tomato and then playing
30 years so it feels like an unbreakable
record it it feels like a a just
coronation everyone will be there and I
hope we get to see history tonight but
if Ernie and those guys were on the call
Thursday I'll be just as excited but if
you feels like that we have two
different Lanes on the highway when we
talk about greatness in basketball there
is the career versus the player LeBron
greatest career
Michael greatest player
that seem like that's uh how we we kind
of I know Bill Russell but Bill
Russell's in a different category there
greatest team player in sports history
yeah but it feels like we look at it
greatest greatest player Michael Jordan
greatest career LeBron James can you
have both
I agree with I I'm actually I've become
so frustrated with the conversation
because it always feels like you're
diminishing one person's accomplishments
um on the other side of that I really
like the way that you set that up and I
also think that people they their facial
reactions show what they care about when
they discuss those two players when they
discuss LeBron it's this and they bring
up numbers
most assists points and it's like that
with Michael Jordan they shake their
head and it's almost like this guy
killed people like this guy was a he was
a monster like it's it's it's a
boogeyman and with LeBron it's it's look
at all the information with Jordan it's
so visceral
uh and I'm wondering I keep saying this
that the prop bet I want is that he
breaks the record with a sky hook but I
haven't seen the prop bet that's on the
other you can bet two point field goal
three-point or uh free throw and I would
like to bet a Skyhook by LeBron you want
those on one of the sports books because
I am a degenerate Gambler there was a
layup dunk jump shot or other yeah and I
would have I would pound other now my
question for you Dan is let's say he's
at he's at let's say it happens tonight
right let's say he's at 34 which means
we're late in the game and let's say
it's close with the thunder on TNT and
he goes Baseline just like Kareem did at
the Thomas and Max Center in Las Vegas
and he loads up and he puts up the hook
and he misses it
can he go back to the hook shot again no
no no no or no okay no to one and done
you you pay tribute to Kareem okay who
does he thank first
after the game or the moment when they
stopped the game
if I was a sports book I would put God
at the best favorite I would say I want
to thank God okay
um and then
I you think he'd do Kareem second or you
think he'd do his mom Gloria I would I
would hope that he would acknowledge
Kareem
well Carmelo did that at the ESPYs
he thanked himself for being great but I
I mean he might LeBron might go JC but
then you know do you do Kareem after
that and then you thank your family and
teammates and Friends those kind of
things I'm still fascinated at the
remember when Nate Robinson had to do a
dunk 17 times in the dunk contest if
like the Lakers are winning but LeBron
keeps shooting hook shots and then they
lose the lead tonight that would be
incredible uh your reaction who got the
better end of the Kyrie Mavs deal with
the Nets
I think when you look at who they
usually say whoever gets the best player
wins the deal
um as someone that was watching the Ben
Simmons deal to James Harden I remember
being flabbergasted watching the media
talk about how the the Nets got Ben
Simmons and how he's such a he's not a a
team cancer like James Harden was and we
saw what happened there the fact that
the Nets got value back for Kyrie Irving
when he has seemingly been so unreliable
for so many different franchises in the
middle of the year when he demanded a
trade and they got it done within days
to get back a really good defender in in
Dorian Finney Smith a fourth best player
on a good team in Spencer Dinwiddie a
future first round pick unprotected I
just there are some guys where I go
who's going to take a flyer on this guy
like who's really going to give up
assets and they found a team so I I
think Kyrie and Luca is going to be a
fun to watch you know I remember coming
on your show when the Nets beat the
Celtics and they were putting up 140
points a game in that playoff series and
you and I talked about how is this the
greatest offense we've ever seen
it's gonna be fun to watch I don't think
it's sustainable I wouldn't bet on it
and and so with all that being said it
all comes down to whether they keep
Kevin Durant well you know you're
starting to hear does KD one out now and
is Boston back in the picture that you
know maybe you bring in Jalen Brown and
you start to rebuild this franchise and
Joe Sai the owner of the net says let me
just be done with it the experiment
didn't work
yeah that's fine but do you really think
that that the the 38 and 16 first place
Boston Celtics are like you know what we
need to do blow it up well you're not
blowing it up but if you can get Kevin
Durant
and you can have him with Jason Tatum
you can you can try to you know you're
going to trade they're gonna Jalen
Brown's not gonna be with them like he's
not going to sign his extension it feels
like he's going to want out to be get
out to be his own team have his own team
you think so yeah I guess is that like a
rumor no I don't know it just did you
just make that up probably so I get the
feeling Brown doesn't want to be there
no no no no no no I'm not saying that
question mark no I just wondered does
Jalen Brown want to have his own team
and I I'm gonna guess after a while you
know you're gonna want your own team but
if I could get Kevin Durant oh
Dan all we ever hear is you can't win
with just one star you got to find a way
to get two together and now suddenly
Jalen's like I think I want to go about
this on my own I I don't getting Kevin
Durant Kevin Durant is the other star
you're getting that other star
I I want so I think one thing that is
really showcasing and by the way I don't
know if Durant wants out I don't know
but I I gotta believe that he's you know
got to think about that
I I totally agree I just want there to
be a new I need a new media organization
maybe it's like a Dan Patrick like part
of your network I want somebody to track
all of these inside reporters with all
their Scoops and I want to start
figuring out who is getting info from
who yeah because what happens is we're
the ones that get played the hosts yes
because we're out there we're going a
lot of rumors right now about Jalen
brown maybe go to the Nets and then we
looked up because the the the Nets are
leaking information about Jalen Brown to
lift up the trade value I I'm seeing
Russell Westbrook to Utah
I just I need someone to figure out
who knows who because we're all getting
played right now and I can't take it
anymore I agree but you know what it is
this is this is what the New Media is
it's wishful reporting and you know you
don't you don't have to have any
accountability once it hey it didn't
happen well you know I was hearing but
it didn't happen uh if you said hey if
you miss on this it cost you ten
thousand dollars your employees taking
away ten thousand like if we if we do a
tote board where we say all right how
many did you get like Shifty got nine in
a row all right you get ninety thousand
dollars you you whiff on one it's gonna
cost you so you have a big tote board
with uh insiders so-called insiders I
would love that yeah I would love that
we we remember the big misses you know
when people report things and it really
doesn't go right yeah I remember a few
years ago when Antonio Brown was going
to the Buffalo Bills for all of like one
night that was fun
um but no I yeah incentivize the actions
you want to see and I it's look the
rumors are fun
but it also is crippling and it's
there's so much going on I do think it's
fascinating that the NFL has tried to
steal everything that the NBA does well
this year every thing they put a game on
Martin Luther King day they put games on
Christmas day which was like an NBA
thing and now in the most important week
in the NFL season the lead up to the
Super Bowl media week LeBron is going to
pass Kareem and the trade deadlines on
Thursday and you know all those NFL
players are being asked about LeBron I
just think it's sweet sweet Vengeance
for the NBA this week he's had him left
go NBA on TNT and uh he'll be uh on uh
on call tonight double duty Suns at the
Nets and uh followed by the Thunder and
the Lakers any other rumors that you're
hearing out there before are the Lakers
going to do anything before the trade
deadline Adam
the the Tim McMahon report that I saw
about sending Westbrook and the two
first round picks possibly to Utah for
Conley and Beasley I think what's
interesting from the Lakers perspective
I heard windhorst talking about it is
they can make a move this year
but if you make if you trade Westbrook
you lose all of that salary cap that's
going to become available and so the
question is is do you think this Lakers
team in a Wide Open West where we just
learned that Stephen Curry is going to
be out for a month do you think that
this is the year to go for it or do you
let Westbrook walk in free agency you
get all that money back and then you go
after Kyrie it reminds me of the Carmelo
situation with the Knicks and the when
the heedles combined where because
Carmelo forced the trade he prevented
himself from joining those guys in New
York so the question is do the Lakers go
for it this year or do they have some
patience well I think they tried to go
for it and and to be honest if they
could have made that move with Kyrie and
not moved Westbrook if you have Anthony
Davis LeBron Westbrook and Kyrie you got
everybody's attention there and and I
think they were I think they were trying
to go for it there and I didn't know if
they would because it felt like they
were saying LeBron well you got us in
this mess you get us out of this mess
and he he didn't get Kyrie to go there
but I I think if you could have kept
those four together
you know now you got there that that's a
match-up that'll be hell come playoff
time but I don't know anything plus the
most amazing thing you just mentioned
that Mike Conley is still playing
basketball
incredible
incredible I see like 40.
he's up there and I'll tell you what if
you watch him on a nightly basis he
looks at sometimes he does but he's got
that veteran voice of course of course
that's what you need come play off time
uh how old is Mike Conley
I got Mike Conley Jr 35 years old oh
okay well how old's Mike Conley senior
maybe that's who I've been watching 80.
okay uh how nervous are you phenomenal
dunker Mike Conley senior phenomenal
well he was a triple jumper
yeah yeah Olympic triple jumper I
believe uh the eagle fan in you how
nervous are you with this matchup coming
up on Sunday
so I'm flying out I'm doing reverse
media you all leave before the game and
you get home in your warm beds I'm
flying out there for the game I just
bought tickets off of an unnamed
Philadelphia Eagles player uh so I'm
hoping they're good I'm also hoping he
didn't scam me because that would really
ruin the Super Bowl for me
heading out there I uh this is very
weird I actually think the city of
Philadelphia right now I'm a little bit
nervous I was there in 2017 2018 and
there was the sheer nerves of what if we
lose again our entire lives all we've
done is lose and there was fear and we
were going up against Brady I'm sensing
a little bit of confidence right now
like we're favorites in this game and
that is really frightening me I will say
from a personal perspective a little bit
of a humble brag but also it's just the
truth I'm really good friends with
Kelsey and Mahomes and so and Andy Reid
was our coach if we were to lose to
anybody I'm glad that it bolsters up
there like greatness and their Hall of
Fame resumes but I really don't want to
hear it from them I do not need to hear
oh but remember that time I beat you in
the Super Bowl that will be I'll have to
live with that the rest of my life then
how about the name dropping by uh Adam
lefk on there legendary first class
pretty good yeah man did uh did I tell
you that I handed out the Super Bowl
trophy uh to the Eagles that time
did you you know was that when
televisions were in black and white yeah
yeah I was there when I was there with
Nick Foles Douglas but they won oh wow
Douglas Peterson you know I was up there
with him Kevin Hart trying to Google it
or when Brady won you know or when Eli
won or when Ben I just dropping some
names can I ask you a can I ask you a
piece of advice you just do so
damn
if LeBron passes Kareem tonight yes are
you one of those broadcasters that you
have a line in the chamber that you want
to hit to honor a big moment or do you
just let it flow I'd let it flow
I just so are you saying that if I was
doing play-by-play or you as a studio
host Tonight
let me do one better I believe that I'm
going to be doing the awards for like
the dunk contest this year okay okay and
I've never given out an award ever so I
like I don't know if I'm gonna be on the
PA or whatever what is the key to that
because I I want to say something clever
but I also want to get out of the way I
would be careful about doing that
because people don't remember that you
do it they only remember when you screw
it up
so that's on you know I I handed out the
trophy what five times
but nobody mentions that I you know did
it because I didn't make mistakes when I
was up there it was just get on and you
know commissioner head coach uh MVP
quarterback and maybe somebody else and
then you throw it back up uh make sure
that you have you know the sound is
correct because you don't want to hear
your Echo and then all of a sudden
you're you're a mess what Paulie or the
danette's think Adam make it all about
you and do like two or three minutes
before you give the award up no it's
your stage no no don't listen to those
guys don't listen to them be clean be
crisp but your personality will come
through okay
Aaron Gordon truly an incredible dunk it
reminds me of my performance at my bar
mitzvah at shiramis synagogue back when
I was 13 years old
I delivered
that is going to go over really well
yeah that I mean you have some people
tuning out because of that but uh you
know go get them you're absolutely right
though Dan it's like we broadcasters a
little bit like offensive lineman if you
if people are talking about us it really
means we messed up here's my advice to
you as I say goodbye take the lahayam
road and I don't think you can go wrong
okay
beautiful to life
and good luck to your egos
I you really knew that you meant
wow
I'm gonna find out that Dan Patrick
changed his name from like Dan Goldstein
back in the day
I am one percent
Jewish
and maybe I rounded up but I'm one
percent according to 23andMe I am a
little over one percent
and I'm going to use it huh
well it's the 23. the part of the the uh
country where uh I have relatives
Boca Raton
amazing thank you Adam enjoy your time
fun tonight have fun tonight
uh that's NBA on TNT tonight
doubleheader Sons Net 7 30 Eastern
followed by Thunder Lakers 10 Eastern
the doubleheader on TNT